now only wait
acceleration come out of calories so for
the wheel
darn
very clearly I am
oh the speed limit is 40 so I'm going to
press the button and raise it to 440 and
also recharge my health bar or the whole
part of the health bar gives you six
minutes just like okay ah and then a
puncher gravity comes with full and
complete stop
I can we showed you the video when we
talk selfie norm if you carefully not
respond for anything stupid and
now unfortunately the carts not have a
automatic windshield wipers - something
I would kind of like to trigger right
now maybe the spot and the wipers even
all the waivers work or that did
something there's one time wipers oh one
time I should be it should be a knob
that you turn you think hard why can't I
press the button would be like a kind of
wipers on a little bit it should be a
bottom on your console or it yeah I mean
like it's here if I need like weird
stalks co-invented cars man combo
quickly if the interface this whole
awkward world mess and Apple made a call
I bet you would have the easiest way to
like to activate the windshield wiper
like the model three everything's on the
now no right no more mine and I'm above
the bad ones are bad thoughts on the car
industry from a self-driving car this is
it this could be this could be like
Richard just this is just like a mod
hahah you know like it also has videos
of the car working and we talk about the
stuff all throughout the household I you
should just record your daily
conversations
getting them tell people it's not
alright mess up there he doesn't like
these I felt like oh my god this is
we're good we rent a video from here
yeah we're good so yeah welcome to the
first episode of economists today we're
we're in a self-driving car we'll call
it so I'm going to raise this because a
little bit here homeless bum down now
instead of sixty five cool thanks is
that went up to 65 my health bar here
have six minutes before if I don't
interact with car for six minutes
um in the morning like they do give you
take control so maybe we'll try to get
there six minutes Honda you're on
I could live with it for you 25 so we're
gonna be well and I will talk about that
later
okay let's see if we can make it to the
postman also we're in a Honda Civic
touring Edition and we are on 80 goes
down
we are running co-pilot zero point three
point six of the latest opus your
experience
on the line and out a little bit that
drips out back
it's quite good at night because
okay all right so that's okay so I
didn't actually have to do anything that
just means that it would like to be
putting more torque I'm steering wheel
than it is but for safety reasons we
limit the torque map so if that comes
off it's just a warning for you to pay
attention it doesn't necessarily mean
with the car can't do it in that case
the car didn't time so yeah you can see
that our health bars now we've spent
about two minutes so far
we're time again where giant old
saturated but that's fine
I mean again oh yeah so that's not
that's not even a limit we can exactly
rain that's bacon computing firmware of
the car the API command we use the
command theory even if you say full
steering
that's all it does and that's one of the
reasons open pilot is obviously man
pulls during tour from the wheels that
would be a taste that require up all
classroom track yeah well we don't yeah
Alden nothing nothing has changed in his
car his cards running all of the stock
on the firmware the only thing we did
was replace the honda autonomous system
with hoping we're about halfway through
the six minutes all right
and this is running on open-source
software running on a comedy connected
up
so I mean it's pretty obvious kind of
the stuff is the green is the latest
nicoleff Allah in the right lane these
purple is past that it thinks the car
should take there's a blue cap
underneath that which is the past the
car is actually taking right now they're
identical gave the Red Cross is off the
car up there and you can see up here
that card 66 cleared away and going with
1 0 minus 1 is how they're just be
together
yeah that's that's the relative speed
between stress as the 65 is my cruise
control is set up see them for the
highway 63 is health after exit going
for going a little bit slower so when
you set the C on the cruise control what
you do is you set the maximum I'm
obviously open Thailand will slow down
in the program
we go around this term as you can see
this bar is still going down I've done
absolutely nothing with the time of f
bar has been ticking down
we got to cut in over here so we're
going to be the first slowing down not
doing that red X jumped over to him
an electric version right the typical
night tonight granted the turns were
nightlight
the turns of the night for a while but I
mean that was in the that was in the
other kids coming here oh yeah on home
college you're off
yeah the old cause there's all the old
cars come here that this is becoming
neo-nazi kids come along come along with
Campbell coming here which is available
free and open source you can download
the plans for this you can also download
the GoPro compiled and run about their
very own coming here
connect them 20 farm and enjoy
test the autopilot level economy
oh the window every one of themselves
so you can control the carbon over the
winter webinar and then our man UX is
hard I'd rather the USGS on the backs of
Canada so you see our our bars are south
so hopefully we'll get to the bottom
office which means I haven't got
anything for six minutes now this is you
know always remember this is a level two
system you have to pay attention at all
time this could make a mistake at any
time but it does still make a lot of a
stage but you know it's not like it's
ever going to slam the steering wheel to
the right
they're always the common mistakes that
you're just like okay I'm going to
graduate right now or I should be
sending a great little harder or
stepping on the gas a little harder um
so our system disengages if you step on
the grapes or the gas which is a lot
which is different most cruise control
systems only just engage as a grand
prize but yeah I mean this is you know
it's either kind of driving on so if
you're engaged this is orange
otherwise it's playing and it also
lights up on your dashboards and if you
know
we're on there we go take control to
regain speed we made it home so yeah
your car will eventually slow down but
I'm going to take control back in the
car that was six minutes fully
autonomous autopilot oh yeah